hey there i'm philip molina and i'm
binging the entirety of jessica jones
and i know you might be too so hopefully
this guide will serve as a great way to
make sure that you don't miss any of the
little things that the show's creators
packed in there for us hang in there
with me as we binge this put on your
binging attire if you got it let's start
at the beginning of course with jessica
jones season 1 episode 1 AKA ladies
night it's an episode all about seeing
the true version of ourselves versus the
one that we put on for people and who
cares about that for a second that
freakin ending was insane but I'm
getting ahead of myself and we will
obviously get back to that let's start
as we always do with the opening images
the episode and the entire series in
fact opens not with us saying Jessica
but instead seeing her point of view
Jessica Jones has a knack for seeing the
worst in people herself included and as
we listen to her thoughts about this we
also get to see through her eyes and
literally her camera lens because as
we'll come to learn the window to the
truth is on the other side of the glass
a moment later and we see the same
opening images from the jessica jones
comics now there was this big question
about whether or not it would be true to
the source material and while I don't
think it's gonna line up perfectly
this shot reminds us that they're not
pretending the comic doesn't exist and
they're definitely not gonna skip out on
the really clever imagery that the
original author Brian Michael Bendis
that he set up for us cuz as you see our
entrance into Jessica's world and her
mind comes through a doorway and it's
not a coincidence that the show is
starting the moment the doorways busted
open and we get a transparent unobscured
view of Jessica also one of the biggest
questions to ponder on throughout this
whole series how far are they gonna take
this show are they gonna venture into
the darkness of the comics and will it
be the furthest most adult thing that
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has ever
shown I'm putting my money on yeah
definitely it will be here but we do
have to acknowledge that the first word
they drop in the comics is the f-bomb
and it's definitely not the first word
of the show so they're still technically
hasn't been one in the MCU as and now at
least that said I don't know that we
need it moving on
Jessica walks on the streets of Hell's
Kitchen which is again a huge difference
from how we normally see Marvel
superheroes getting around town aside
from daredevil least notice how even the
sites
the skyscrapers are from the street
perspective and they're kind of visiting
there's a little bit of a blurry edge if
you notice that's definitely pointing
out that our girl who like us
she's street level then we quickly don't
really meet Pam Gerry's assistant but we
do meet Gerry Hogarth and that's the
character that's based on jeryn hogarth
on the comics and she's someone who's
very likely gonna play a large role in
this show but mostly a lot of people
think she's gonna set up the eventual
Iron Fist show which Marvel by the way
is definitely confirming is still on the
way now Jessica normally works for
individuals that are privately seeking
her help but this relationship with
Hogarth where she's doing odd jobs for
her law firm it kind of reminds me of
the way that Jessica in the comics
eventually works for Jay jonah Jameson
of all people so I think this is likely
inspired by their arrangement after we
see Jessica on her throne which is
another comics reference we then see her
take a drink and very reluctantly climb
into bed like look at the way she looks
at the bed the bed's a classic symbol
for the enema see between lovers and
this is telling us she kind of dreads
that idea and even it probably hates
going to bed each night so it's no
surprise that she doesn't stay in there
very long and also did you notice that
she sleeps with the lights on I think
this is all some foreshadowing of
Jessica being really afraid of something
Jessica then hops under a fire escape to
seemingly just spy on people but this
image of looking through windows from
the outside spine and on people seeing
their truth gaining access to their
private life this is definitely gonna be
a recurring theme on this show and I
know that because they put in the
frickin opening credits oh and one of
the people she's spying on Luke Cage
being a ladies man and this is the
second time we meet a character through
a doorway though we only see a glimpse
of his truth through a window and that
yellow shirt he's wearing is a nice nod
to his superhero costume from back in
the day also early in the comics she's
accidentally spying on Captain America
so I think this is our shows version of
that then we get our first PTSD flash
into purple as that killgrave silhouette
scares the crap out of us note the way
he suddenly pushes himself into the
frame and like he pushes himself into
her mind it's why we're just as scared
of that moment as she is and the
street-name she starts reciting
it's dry they're the same ones that we
saw in that trailer a while back and
while we don't still know what the
significance of them is she's definitely
using them in some sort of psychological
calming way I'm gonna get back to that
actually after some more peeking through
doorways we meet a confused kind of
accidental intruder who's Malcolm
Jessica's junkie neighbor he's come a
long way down from being just kind of
annoying in the comics but Jessica can't
really judge him cuz when she gets drunk
she's done this like exact same thing a
few times or so Jessica then gets some
clients that are looking for their
daughter who hasn't actually gone
missing she just hasn't seemed to be
herself lately and checking in on that
foreshadowing with the door motif know
how the girl's dad keeps making sure to
point out that the entrance into
Jessica's security her door is very
broken and despite what Jessica may
think as the dad points out she doesn't
have the tools to fix it kind of sounds
like someone's gonna get past that into
her safe space later Jessica meets the
girls roommates and reveals that she
hates being on the other side of the
camera
seriously lose the camera Coppola
because she obviously knows that the
glass reveals way too much about people
and she doesn't want to give anybody
that kind of access it's like she
probably doesn't have an Instagram
account what a crazy person now is
Jessica completes that task that hogarth
had assigned to her she shows off some
of her super-strength and makes a joke
about having laser eyes and it's clear
she's more than okay with bullshitting
about her powers which is something they
kept from the comics but I think this is
actually more a little bit of a hint of
why people are so scared of
super-powered people and why we're
eventually gonna get to all-out Civil
War however something I think is way
more interesting about the scene is when
they actually shot it apparently this
was the coldest day in New York history
and it was so cold that the actress
Kristin ritter mentioned that her eyes
kept tearing up but the tears wouldn't
fall away they would gather and freeze
in the corner of her eyes and she
actually developed these small little
sores from that so it might not have
been intentional but can you think of a
better metaphor about our characters
tragic state her tears never properly
left her they froze in place and so
those old tears end up creating new
wounds for damn it's like mother nature
needs a producing credit on this show oh
and uh
after that moment we get our first
nominee for like the sickest most
unsettling moment of this episode when
another PTSD flashback to kilgrave shows
him freakin licking her across the face
which uh what a freakin invasion later
Jessica once again avoids a door to
access people and she pierced her
windows instead to try to see them
truthfully but Luke finds her and they
get to know each other a little bit
which is different from the comics where
they already know each other but it
gives us this great little line about
how
Jessica tried a different job out and
this is the new job feel good going to
work she found your work I did that I'm
working the new work and the reason I
like that line is it's an
acknowledgement of her past of trying to
be a traditional superhero named jewel
and I just want to see a lot more
references to that I also gotta say that
these actors completely nailed the
chemistry which is why I actually
completely like believe the moment where
it just hilariously just jumps right to
sex like that's a superpower that I've
had a bunch of people wish they could
have and the sex scene is totally loaded
with stuff that is not a pun by the way
that I just mean there's a lot to
comment on first off the bat is the
reference to breaking where Jessica
actually wants him to take it harder on
her and he's reluctant okay we think
yeah you will they're both referencing
each other's powers at that moment but
neither realizes it so that's cool and
then we get the infamous flip over that
we were all wondering if we'd see and
yeah we see it and they included the
pained face we can't read Jessica's
thoughts like we could in the comic but
it's really telling that she made him
flip her over because she couldn't take
facing him and looking into his eyes not
surprising that it ends up being really
awkward for them and awkward sex that
leads to tears that's definitely not
something we normally see in the MCU so
let's acknowledge that we're off to a
really good start for those of us that
want to see gritty realism in this show
I also think this might be the first
straight-up like superhero on superhero
sex scene in the MCU take note of the
moment that breaks Jessica by the way
which Luke was right she did break it's
when she sees this photograph of a woman
in his medicine cabinet it's also worth
noting that's not the same lady we saw
before clearly there's something special
about her if he's keeping her picture
hidden like that
so just continues on her mission to find
hope
missing girl and we see this fancy
purple tie it's foreshadowing that hope
is probably in some real danger grave
danger kilgrave did you probably get it
you got it just starts to piece together
what's going on when the path leads her
to a restaurant that her captor kilgrave
had taken her to and then we get our
first flashback to where we see her
fully under the control of killgrave
obviously the purple is like
overwhelming but notice they really went
out of their way to at least make it
seem like he's got purple skin at that
moment although I think it's just a
lighting thing the episode really shifts
tone here and it does not turn back
again preferring the windows to the
doors just pays a visit to Trish Walker
who this all confirms is the replacement
for her friend Captain Marvel in the
comics and just tells her that she's
still not a hero at least not the one
that Trish wants her to be which is
another cool reference to her days as
Jul but then just tries to run away and
she can't because she's got a hero's
heart or courage or something and she
goes to where she knows killgrave is
probably keeping hope in that hotel
those fire alarm flashes are really nice
parallel to the lightning and purple
storm that we saw in the trailer a while
back and the hotel room itself we do
kind of recognize because it's where
kilgrave took Jessica to in the comet so
jessica rescues hope and has her parents
pick her up and just when you think the
show might be the kind that has a cute
little story of the week and then it has
a happy ending yeah that doesn't happen
Jessica was right about not trusting
what people look like on the other side
of a doorway because it turns out hope
is still under a kilgrave's mind-control
and she freaking murders both her
parents and God that freaking moment
where she gives the creepy smile and
tells doesn't got a smile definitely the
winner of the thing I said before of
most unsettling moments of the episode
but it's followed by that almost worse
heartbreaking moment when kilgrave's
mind-control wears off and she sees what
she's done and like oh my god welcome to
the new Marvel Cinematic Universe hope
you have a flashlight kilgrave is so
sadistic like he planned this whole
thing he's manipulating Jessica into
thinking she could actually control
something but we all know he's in
control of everything apparently like
even what we think we're seeing he's in
control Oh suddenly it's
very clear right there in all of its
freaking purpleness dammit kilgrave well
played but damn alright in our closing
images we see Jessica run out of the
building ready to skip town and run away
from the story run away from her life
ran away from all of it but she changes
her mind and she turns back and just
like how we met her in the beginning
through a transparent doorway we now
meet Jessica Jones the hero who's ready
to take on killgrave as she travels
through another transparent doorway okay
lingering thoughts there was some really
great detective work in there like her
analysis of Luke and I just like that
they're making her a really good
detective it's great I also love that
they got in the purple man stuff
immediately other than like in the
comics it's like all the way the back
five issues and that's a good moment to
point out that we haven't even met this
guy yet and we're already terrified of
him oh and also the thing I said I'd
come back to you about Higgins and birch
and Street Drive I think that's yeah a
way that Jessica's trying to bring
herself back from mind control or
something but I feel like this kind of
makes sense they're gonna have to do
something like that something more based
in psychology and science cuz in the
comic she gets help from Jean Grey the
psychic of the x-men as we know that's
owned by Fox and copyright laws suck
okay I can't wait to move on to episode
2 as I'm sure you can't either so click
here to go to my analysis of that and if
I haven't shot it yet but I will by the
time that's available geek out with me
about this show on Twitter at fimo and
in general just let me know what you
thought about this episode in the
comments below do me a favor of you
binge the head of us try not to talk
about the spoilers from the upcoming
episode so we can talk about those when
I do those videos in the meantime i'm
philip molina and let's get back to
binging